[Musique]
elles avaient toujours tendance à me
dire non ne te décourage pas nous nos
objectifs c'était tellement source de
motivation en fait
elles étaient tout pour moi
[Musique]
donc il nous en frappé
il nous enfouiller et après ils nous
abandonné la sous le soleil il y avait
pas d'enclos où nous abriter et
j'oubliais de préciser qu'ils ont pris
ils ont récupéré nos téléphones et nos
pièces d'identité mon téléphone qu'ils
ont cassé devant nous
[Musique]
une fois au désert avec les autres moi
j'étais à bout vu que ça faisait quatre
jours de marché
sans pouvoir manger sans nous hydrater
donc à peine 30 minutes de marche au
désert moi je me suis écroulé je me suis
écroulé vu que j'avais plus de force ma
femme est restée à mes côtés avec
l'enfant elle me demande d'essayer de me
lever de continuer avec elle pouvait pas
continuer je sentais plus je sentais que
c'était fini pour moi
dans ma tête c'était que c'est la mort
j'ai demandé à ma femme de partir de me
laisser
d'essayer de sauver au moins l'enfant
[Musique]
j'aurais préféré mourir avec elle en
fait
j'aurais préféré peut-être qu'on
découvre trois cadavres dans le désert
parce que là c'est ce que je suis mort
j'ai plus personne
[Musique]